- All right, hello, everyone.
My name's Ian McKiernan.
I'm the lead product manager
for the NBA Stats Platform,
and we're here to talk to you today
about the NBA's new
Inside the Game platform
with AWS along with...
- Dashiell Flynn or "Dash."
I'm a principal consultant in
our sports practice at AWS.
I lead a lot of our AI/ML
data and analytics projects
across our league team
and sports customers.
- Right, and I'm Charlie Rohlf.
I get the honor of leading
the NBA Stats team,
and I'll kick it off here
with the slide presentation.
This is our 300 level talk
about Inside the Game.
We're excited to talk about the NBA,
what we're doing with AWS.
I am a retired 500 level engineer
who can no longer cut it at that level,
so I'm appropriate at
the 300 level for today.
So, can everyone hear me okay?
Yes, excellent.
My first presentation to
green earmuffs all around.
So, thank you.
But let's start with our
customary hype video as the NBA.
We put a lot of effort into our marketing,
but this is great to get us excited,
and then we'll get into
what the Inside the Game platform does,
what our team does, and go from there.
We're excited for the presentation.
So with that, enjoy.
- [Commentator] James fly.
Got it!
(spirited music)
(crowd cheering)
(indistinct)
Got it!
♪ It' game time ♪
(upbeat music)
(indistinct)
(crowd cheering)
♪ Step on the shooters (indistinct) ♪
♪ I cannot keep up with the best ♪
- [Commentator] Down by three.
(indistinct)
Tosses it up.
Oh!
(upbeat music continues)
It's pure basketball poetry.
♪ It's game time ♪
(indistinct)
Great, so with that, we wanted to unveil
the Inside the Game platform,
which from the NBA, empowered by AWS.
And we're excited to talk
to you about that today.
But first, we have to start
with a little bit of
background and context.
So you'll see on the loop there
this expected field goal percentage,
and we'll talk more about that later.
But what I really wanna highlight
before we move into our team
are those little green dots
all over Luca's body, right?
That represents our player tracking data
and it underpins a lot of what we do here.
So we are generating 29 data points.
Wrists, shoulder, elbows,
shoulders, knees, hips, et cetera.
29 body parts of every player,
60 times a second throughout
the course of the game
in three dimensions.
And you can see those little green dots.
They represent an X, Y, Z
coordinate of every player
60 times a second.
It's an incredible amount of data.
The scope of that data really speaks
to the scope of our team.
And to understand what
Inside the Game does
and how we did it, we have to
start with what our team does.
So our stats team handles
everything on the screen here.
It's everything in the backend
related to the basketball data,
the data that describes
the game on the court.
So we do the ingestion and storage,
wherever that data comes from,
whether it's a partner,
whether it's internal.
Whatever data describes
the game on the court,
we're taking it in, we're
ingesting it, we're storing it,
we're processing it, we're ETL-ing,
we're keeping it for the
historical record books
and doing that generation in the middle
where we add intelligence to it.
And that's really where
Inside the Game shines,
where we try to add
intelligence to the content,
to the data.
We wanna tell stories with the data.
And then ultimately, we
have to deliver that data.
We want to take that data and
deliver it to our products,
deliver it to our teams,
to our broadcasters,
and ultimately our fans, right?
Because if we have one mission,
our mission is to educate and engage fans.
So we have built this
Inside the Game platform
to educate and engage our fans
and take that data,
tell compelling stories,
and help our fans
understand the game better,
understand why great players are so great,
what makes them the best
athletes in the world, right?
Why are the teams succeeding?
Why is another team struggling?
We wanna be able to use
data to tell those stories.
Because the more we can
educate, the more we can engage,
it will lead to better broadcasts,
better engage with our digital products,
and generally, better business outcomes.
But, you know, since we're
operating at the 300 level here,
you can see the scope
of our team is broad.
Like, we're only gonna
cover a slice of this
with the Inside the Game platform.
But I'm lucky to lead a team
of extremely talented engineers
and product managers that
handle all of the steps on here
and happy to answer
questions about it as we go.
So, the first thing to
drill in a little bit more,
and again, we're gonna go
into that content generation.
That's where the Inside
the Game really shines.
And while AWS has stepped in
to be an incredible partner
across the whole stack,
our entire tech stack,
and amplified our mission
to educate and engage fans,
really, from day one,
we're gonna focus on how Inside the Game
renders for our fans.
And in order to do that, we
have to understand sort of,
what are we trying to do?
We're trying to quantify a play.
So, in case you're not
a basketball expert,
let's just show a play,
and we'll jump back to this later.
But with Giannis here,
he's gonna get a lot of attention
in defense, kick it out.
Nice little cue pass there
for a three in the corner.
So that's a play.
But the moment team got the
balls, end of the possession.
But not every play is the same.
Some plays are a distinct moment in time,
some plays span a lot of time.
But ultimately, what we're trying to do
is quantify the action
and quantify that play.
But there's a lot of history here
that we need to understand.
We've come a long way.
You remember that shot of Luca
with the 29 data points on his body?
It wasn't always that way.
We have on the screen here
a shot of the scorebook
from Wilt's 100-point game.
It used to be a play like that,
a play like Giannis with a
kickout and a give and go,
or all those plays were really,
at best, one data point.
Just one data point.
If they scored.
What was the score?
That was the only data point we had.
And over time, we added data points.
So we got to the point where we had shots
and misses and makes,
and then we had rebounds
and we had assists.
And over the years, we
added more and more stats
and it became the box score that you knew.
But then the box score wasn't enough.
There's only so much you could do
'cause you'd have the
aggregate of all the stats,
but you needed the play by play.
You needed the temporal aspect.
When did they happen?
Who was on the court?
Then we had the play by play.
So from 1996 onward, we
had the play by play.
So we would know the time of each event,
and then we could tell
you who was on the court
and which lineups were efficient.
And we could really measure
the success of each player
in a different way from '96 onward.
But you're still talking about
relatively little data, right,
compared to the scale
we're dealing with now.
And it took a big leap forward
when we added player tracking data.
A little over 10 years ago,
we started with just a single
data point for every player,
an X, Y, Z coordinate of
the player on the court
as they moved around in your
high school geometry class.
That was a big leap, a stepwise leap.
And then we took another step forward
in the last three years where
we moved to that pose data,
as we call it, right?
That's the head,
shoulders, knees and toes,
the skeletal pose data of the players,
60 times a second, 29 body parts.
And then imagine what that unlocks
when you're trying to
quantify a play that we saw.
And you can see our
little dancing skeletons,
as we like to call them,
matched up to the video.
But that's what the data looks like
when you just play it out.
Right?
It's an incredible data set.
There's so much we can do.
And in many ways, we're
only scratching the surface
of what's possible.
But we now work with AWS
to take in all this data
and think of that pipeline
we showed in the early slide,
ingest it, store it, process
it, do live real-time
split second data science
through our Flink architecture,
running seamlessly on AWS and
deliver it to our products,
our broadcasters, our teams so
that they can make use of it.
And really, back to that
quantifying a play idea,
that amount of data is incredible, right?
Millions, literally,
millions of data points
for every single play.
We went from one to millions.
But we can't take millions of data points
and give millions of data
points to a broadcaster.
We can't give millions of data
points to a coach or a fan.
They're not gonna know
what to do with that.
So a lot of the work we
do when we quantify a play
is how do we understand
the aspects of the game
and quantify the specific
basketball things
that a broadcaster can then act on
or an insight we can give the fan
to engage them and educate them
about what they're seeing on the court.
And all these aspects go into it.
And we'll talk more over the
course of this presentation
about how we prioritize all the things
we could do with the stats.
But again, it all boils down to this idea
of how do we quantify a play.
And not every play is the same.
As I mentioned,
we have our expected field
goal percentage, XFG.
That takes in all these features.
The pose of the shooter,
how closely defended were
they when they shot it?
Were they leaning?
Were they coming off a screen?
How fast were they running?
All those aspects of a
single moment in time,
that moment of a shot, that's
part of quantifying a play.
We can tell you how
effectively shooters shoot,
like, what's the expected
field goal percentage,
which shooters exceed the
expected field goal percentage,
which don't quite do that.
But that's just a moment in time.
That's a play.
But so is something like
a horns action, right?
Double high ball screen.
There's a hundred variations
of this that teams run,
but that spans a long time.
So there's not one size fits all, right?
There's a lot of different
plays to quantify.
But ultimately, if we quantify the play
and we can identify it
and use AI and ML to find that shot,
to find the features
that describe that shot,
to build the AI model, the ML model,
to pull out the expected
field goal percentage,
to detect that horn's action.
Once we find it, after we find it,
then we can quantify and
we can tell you tendencies,
frequencies, efficiencies, where
on the court do they do it?
How often does LeBron go
to his left or his right more often?
What happens when he goes
to his left and his right?
But the first step is always finding it.
You have to quantify the play.
From that, then you can
generate the insights
and you can go from there.
And we're so excited to go into how AWS
has helped us really amplify that goal
of educating and engaging fans
through quantifying these plays
and generating these cool new stats
that we're gonna show off today.
So with that, I will hand it over to Dash
to talk about the program overall.
- Thank you, Charlie, very much.
At AWS, we're very excited to
be partnering with the NBA.
I think as we've gotten
into our overall objective,
we really see this as an
innovation partnership
across the organization
and that the NBA is really
living up to its reputation
as the most innovative
professional league we have here.
And so what we started to build out
is that overall partnership framework
and how do we start to
develop these capabilities
over a five-year period of the partnership
and how are we leveraging
core AWS services
and combining that with the wealth of data
Charlie was talking to at the NBA.
So how do you take those three years,
this third season of post data
and start to develop insights?
How are you starting to
look at 14 plus years
of tracking data that center of mass
and start to develop
pull out insights there,
and how do you start to do that at scale?
So setting the foundation
of really being able
to apply different services
for different outcomes
and where are we leading to
with that foundation of integration
of NBA's data with AWS services.
On top of that core foundation,
we're really looking to build out scale.
So how do we start to scale
across the organization
and help the NBA move
faster at higher volume
with the same kind of resource inputs?
And so that's really where the
basketball insights platform
is designed to build out
those core foundations, right?
And so to be able to build things once,
and then scale it across the organization.
So if you have an integrated pipeline
for pose and video
connections, synchronization,
you use that for advanced stats as we are,
but also helpful for player health
and looking at biomechanics
and those sorts of data.
So you can use it once
across the organization.
Or you're building distribution pipelines.
You're building those
ones and scaling them.
So really, that core
engine and that platform
that enables the organization
to scale at speed
and help these guys
start to develop rapidly
at an innovation pace that
we had AWS build around.
And then from there,
then we start to get into
the individual products
and services that we're building.
So you see here,
what we've started with so far
is what we call Play Finder,
which is the ability to search
for any play or any similar play
in the history of that tracking data.
So you can start to either just say,
"I wanna see LeBron dunks."
Or a fan can design a play.
I wanna run a horns action into elevators
into an open, you know, corner three.
How do you find that play
and how do you put that in
to be able to search and
pull back the most similar,
how do you filter that
down to your favorite team,
your favorite player involved,
those kind of capabilities.
And so those products and services
are gonna be a suite of capabilities
that we build out together over time
that add to that top layer
for more and more inputs
and engagement with fans,
supporting teams, supporting
the organization, et cetera.
And then today where we're
really investing into
or showing is the advanced
Stats Platform, right?
And what are those
additional new advanced stats
that we're able to develop
and leverage our AI
and machine learning services
to start to draw out the insights
and start to understand
nuances of the game
in a measurable way that we
haven't been able to previously.
And that's where we sort of, you know,
how do we get there and how do we start,
you know, really being able to look
at how do the core Stats
Platform migrate over
and welcome Ian up to talk through
how that migration happened
and how it's led into where we are today
and what we're launching with Gravity.
- Thanks, Dash.
Yeah, so we're gonna start
with how we migrated the platform over.
There was a whole conversation
about moving the whole NBA over yesterday.
But small piece of that
was the Stats Platform.
We'll go through that.
Then we're gonna go a little bit
through the stats ideation process
and we'll finish up by
looking specifically
at the new stat that
was released last week
on private video broadcast.
So with migrating the
advanced Stats Platform,
Charlie talked about it.
We have many different
operations within the stats team.
So we had to migrate our
historical data warehouse,
we have our live stats processing
and delivering those VR APIs.
And then we have our real-time
player tracking data,
which included moving
terabytes of data over to AWS,
which there were many tools available
to help us do that
effectively and efficiently.
But that also includes the live processing
of that player tracking data
and getting that out to our fans.
And I'm gonna go into details
more about that architecture
and how we migrated that
over on the next slide.
But we also have our stats alert system,
which is a real-time
data science application,
which is looking for
insights using data science
to look for outliers, right?
Career highs.
This player has scored or counted 80%
of his team's points in a quarter.
Or this team is going on a run, right?
And we're able to alert our broadcasters
and tell stories to our fans through that.
And then we have our data science tools
and our development environment
we've migrated over as well.
So all of this had to go
over a lot of moving pieces,
but there are a lot of tools in AWS
and great products on there
for us to migrate over to.
So this is a look at our real-time
player tracking infrastructure.
This is one of our more complicated
pieces of infrastructure, right?
We have a lot of data
stored terabyte stored in S3
as the background of this.
And then we're running a
lot of Kubernetes operations
and EKS that need to talk to each other
with low latency, right?
This needs to move quick.
From the time the data
leaves the RabbitMQ topic
in the arena, right?
This whole operation is only
adding about 50 milliseconds
to reaching the end user
at the other side of the API, right?
So we're moving about 10
streams a game, right?
And this needs to scale, obviously.
'Cause we can have 12 concurrent games.
That first set of games, two
games went into overtime.
They're sending data
from the G League game earlier that day.
This system needs to scale, right?
It needs to scale back
down and be cost-effective
and needs to be reliable and fast, right?
And we've been able to do
that with EKS on AWS, right?
So we have our optimal
feed service, right?
That tells the shepherd spawner,
"Hey, there's a game coming up."
The Shepherd Spawner
sponsor Shepherd that says,
"Hey, make sure that everything's
running for this game."
That Shepherd will then
spin up a number of pods
that we call listeners here
that move data from the RabbitMQ topics
to an internal Kafka topic.
We have listeners that then move that data
to S3 for future use.
We have Flink applications
that are spun up.
We spin up close to a hundred
Flink applications a game
to calculate in real-time player
speed and movement, angles
and create these building
blocks that we use
to then create the stats
that you see headlining inside the game.
There's a lot of little
pieces that go into that
in this infrastructure that add up
to Player Gravity, for example,
which we're gonna talk
about a little later, right?
And then we have listeners
that move that data
to an external facing kafka topic
that feeds our API for
users to consume that data.
So like I said, all of this...
And then it's scaled.
You know, this should be three dimension.
We see we have a live
version of this, right?
And we have a historical version.
So we prioritize that
live data for live games,
and then a historical games or process
on a different node pool.
But everything's able to happen
within the same environment,
within the same node pool.
So minimize the networking
costs or overhead
and get that data through
as quickly as possible
to the end user.
And we're able to do that very effectively
using these AWS products.
So how do we come up with a stat though?
We have that infrastructure.
When you wanna build something on it,
how do we do that, right?
Well, we start with a
couple of questions, right?
Where are the gaps in
the stats discourses?
What are people talking about?
What do we all intuitively know
about the game when we watch it,
but there's no way to talk
about it with numbers, right?
And so one thing is defensive value.
And we've been able to target this
with our Defensive Box Score.
We have steels and blocks,
which we have had for a long time, right?
But our Defensive Box Score has allowed us
to go a step deeper to
see who is guarding who
for what period of time
and what stats do they accumulate
during that period of time, right?
And so this is one way
that we can look deeper
and add context to that
conversation about which players
are adding defensive value to their team.
Offensive process.
Which team gets the best shots, right?
Not who scores the most.
You know that.
Just look at the score, right?
But which team got the best shots?
A team can use that to look and say,
"Well, did we have the right process?
Maybe we don't need to change
our game plan for the next game.
Because you know what?
We got great shots.
We just didn't hit them," right?
And we're able to do that
with our expected field
goal percentage metric
and shots over expected there.
And then another thing,
impact without scoring.
We all know hustle players, you know,
steals, rebounds, blocks, assist,
the guy who's everywhere on the court,
but maybe doesn't fill
out the statute, right?
How can we quantify that?
These are just some areas
that we're looking to explore
when we come up with a new stat.
Then we're talking to our fans,
our broadcast partners and teams,
and what are they highlighting, right?
In the discourse, earlier this year,
we heard a lot of talk
about Player Gravity,
which players are drawing
the defense towards them,
morphing the defense
and creating open shots
for their teammates.
Well, everyone notices that on the court,
the Giannis clip that Charlie
showed earlier, right?
But how do we quantify that?
Well, with Player Gravity,
which we're gonna talk about next,
we're able to do just that.
Shot Makers, our expected
field goal percentage.
That's shot's made above expected, right?
This is a way for us to quantify
who the best shot makers are
and have a discussion about it.
Add that context for
fans and not just say,
"Well he's my favorite player,
that's your favorite player,
who's better, right?"
And then lastly, as Charlie talked about,
we're in a very data rich environment,
but what data do we have available, right?
We have the box score
and the play by play.
We may need to join back to that.
We have player tracking data.
And then I talked a little bit
about these NBA developed stats,
which are the building blocks
towards some of these
larger headline stats.
One of the things underlying
our Player Gravity metric
and our Defensive Box Score
is a defensive pressure score.
Something that's not really talked about.
Go into a little bit more
detail about that later.
But essentially, quantifying
defensive principles.
Everyone's heard ball you man, right?
Rec basketball, stay between
your man in the basket, right?
We've been able to create an algorithm
that measures the amount of pressure
that each defender is putting
on each offensive player, right?
And through that,
we're able to use an
optimization algorithm
that maximizes total
team defensive pressure
to figure out which player
should be matched up
with which player at any
given moment in time,
which helps us make our
Defensive Box Scores
and also helps us with Player Gravity.
And the next slide,
because everyone loves
a good flow chart here,
it's really, how we go
through this process?
What do we wanna measure.
Do we have the data to measure it?
If no, can we collect the data, right?
If yes, we go back to
the front and start again
and hopefully get to the left
side of the tree this time.
If no, we have to wait for technology
to catch up sometimes, right?
And that's where the player
tracking data comes in.
In this data rich environment,
we do have the opportunity
to look at things
we've never looked at before
and get more to the left
side of this tree, right?
If we do have the data,
will it require a model?
No?
Great.
We can start building it.
If it does, does it require labels,
and you guys get the rest, right?
But this is basically the
workflow that we go through
when we're coming up with our new stats,
trying to figure out
how we can build something for the fans,
for the broadcasters, for
our teams that's meaningful
and provide more context and insights
as part of the Inside the Game platform.
So specifically, let's
talk about Player Gravity.
This is this play that we watched earlier.
We'll it again one more time
and go into a little bit more detail.
You'll see a moment here
where Giannis drives.
He's gonna draw all
three of these defenders,
and that starts this turn.
Miles Turner's open.
Behind the back pass to (indistinct).
Knocks down the three, right?
This moment in time right here,
or in the traditional box score,
Giannis gets no credit, right?
Maybe, maybe in the new age
where we have some
secondary assist metrics,
you can quantify some of that value.
But really, this is what starts the churn
and gets the play open
and creates that open shot at the end.
But we've had no way to
quantify that until now, right?
And so here is some of what
we're working on under the hood
where as these...
The plays flipped.
But as Giannis is dribbling here,
you'll see the defensive pressure scores
are being calculated in real-time, right?
And you'll see we have actual sum DPS,
sum defensive pressure scores.
Expected some DPS.
Expected pressure scores, right?
It's a key piece of the Gravity model
that we have developed with AWS, right?
But what this allows us to do is quantify
which players are getting more
attention from the defense
than we would expect from
the average player, right?
So a little bit more on
the gravity definition,
but we have that actual DPS, right?
So we're doing pair-wise,
defensive pressure,.
25 defensive pressure scores,
calculated at 60 frames
a second in real-time
based on player speed and
movement angles, how far they are,
how far they are relative to the basket,
other things like that
go into the actual
defensive pressure score,
where the ball is where you
are, where the basket is, right?
We can calculate that.
Or we've been calculating
that for a few years now.
What AWS has helped us develop
is an expected defensive
pressure score model,
which is a machine learning
model, which takes the inputs
of the offensive positioning and the ball
and tells us where we expect,
essentially, where we expect the defense
to be standing based on
where the offensive players
in the ball are.
And what this allows us to do,
like I said, if we take
the actual minus expected,
we get attention from the
defense above expected,
which seems like a pretty
straightforward definition
for Player Gravity.
And so we're really excited
for what this can do.
But a little bit more
about that expected pressure score model.
As I said, we take the defense out
and basically the model learns.
This is a similar architecture
to the coverage model
that was being talked about at the NFL.
But using factorized attention
and a transformer architecture,
we're able to feed the player locations
over a two-second period,
as well as trajectories,
time, and score into the model
to understand where do we
expect the defense to be
in this situation.
So if your man is pulled in,
you know, if that's Joel
Embiid at the high post
and that guy in the corner
takes a step closer,
this model is gonna pick that
up as being more attention
than otherwise would be
had at that high post area,
giving more Gravity to a
player like Joel Embiid.
So we're really excited
about this application.
And as you can see from
the actual leaderboard,
current leaderboards for
the season as of last week,
anyone who's a fan probably
expected Steph Curry
to be at the top.
So we know the model's working.
We're done, right?
No.
But what this allows us to do
is have intelligent conversations, right?
Everyone expects Steph
Curry to be at the top,
but maybe you're asking
why is Michael Porter Jr. second, right?
He's on a struggling team.
He may be one of the better
players on a struggling team,
and therefore the defense is able to throw
more attention at him.
And so what this allows us to do
with teams and fans and broadcasters
is have those intelligent conversations
about what team strategies
are being applied.
Maybe one team produces
more gravity in general
because they're pressuring up
more than is expected, right?
And we're able to quantify that now
and we're able to see those
differences and evaluate that
both in real-time for our broadcast
and show that to our fans,
but also over the course of
seasons and different games
and compare those numbers.
So you'll see the rest
of the list though looks,
you know, looks pretty
good from the eye test.
So, like I said, really excited.
This was launched last week
on the Prime Video broadcast,
and we're excited to bring it
to the Inside the Game platform
online in the coming weeks.
But I'm gonna pass it back to Charlie
to talk about what's coming in the future.
- Thank you, Ian.
Before we go about it,
I just wanted to bring this back
to what we talked about at the beginning
and think through how that data
science achievement, right,
of analyzing the tracking data,
coming up with defensive pressure score,
developing the ML model for actual
and expected defensive pressure score,
and ultimately resulting in gravity.
That data science effort,
that achievement manifests
in a lot of different things.
You see the leaderboard here.
This is a great fan engagement tool.
It's a new leaderboard.
It speaks to aspect of
defense and offensive pull
that we've never been
able to quantify before.
And that's a great fan engagement tool.
But it's also every moment of the game,
it can turn into something that
we generate for highlights,
helping broadcasters see
a specific Gravity play
and the color commentator speak
to it as Stan Van Gundy did
on the first prime video broadcast, right?
And so it touches so many
aspects of our business
and it also touches all the aspects
of that stats infrastructure.
And that's really why AWS
has been a great partner
and able to amplify our mission
of educating and engaging fans.
They've come in and helped
us with the database layer,
the ingestion layer, the
data science aspects,
all the parts that go into
creating this leaderboard.
Comes out as a leaderboard,
but there's so much work
along the way, right?
And we're so appreciative
of AWS's contributions
to all the steps that go into this
and all the other ways
that Gravity will impact
our fans, our broadcasters,
help our teams analyze
the game in a new way.
So what's to come, right?
Looking ahead, some of
our tentpole events here.
Rivalries Week, All-Star.
You've seen Defensive Box
Score, Shot Difficulty,
we talked about the outset,
the expected field goal percentage.
We just released Gravity here
on the Black Friday broadcast.
Next up is our Leverage Score.
And that's a look at
how players contribute
to the team's chances of winning.
And it's not just points, it's
their rebounds, the steals,
getting a defensive
rebound in a clutch moment.
We're building a new model
that will measure those players' impact
and how each player has helped
their team win the game.
For All-Star, we're
targeting handle score.
That'll be a fun model that really speaks
to how players handle the ball.
The great crossovers, the
spin moves, behind the back,
and a fun metric that'll
speak to the great athletes
in the incredible way, what
they can do with the ball
and how they can move around the game.
And that will come out around All-Star.
But then let's not forget
about the WNBA too, right?
AWS is coming in.
We're gonna work same
stats team on our end.
We work with the W basketball data,
and we're excited for what
we can do with the WNBA.
And we're looking at
things around chemistry.
And we're honestly still
kicking around ideas,
but how do we speak to
the player's chemistry
and who interacts with each other
and how do they pass to each
other, the types of passes.
We're looking at rebound prediction
or we're looking at triple threat.
And we love stats that are
easy for fans to understand,
or we want to make the
most impact we can make
with the stats that we do.
So how do we develop stats
that are both compelling
from a data science standpoint, right,
push the industry forward
from basketball analytics,
help our teams, but are
ultimately approachable.
So that fans, no matter your
interest level in the NBA,
whether you're a novice or
you're a hardcore stat fan
and basketball nerd like me,
is it's something engaging,
something that will help you
and something that will
teach you about the game.
And we try to find things
that are approachable at all those levels.
So hopefully you'll have some questions.
Finally, we'll end with where to watch.
Right here.
Watch right here.
We're gonna have the
happy hour in the game
after the next session.
But appreciate all our
broadcast partners, ABC, NBC,
and Prime Video, Peacock right there.
And hopefully to see you all
at the upcoming happy hour
where we can turn on
the game and learn more.
But with that, we would
love for some questions
from the group.
- [Ian] Should we stand up?
- We have the mics ready in the back.
All right.
Who's gonna break the ice?
- [Audience Member] Hey.
Sir.
Hi there.
Do you think this data
is gonna make its way
into the next generation of video games?
Like, if you introduce these
concepts, you'll see that.
And kind of the follow up to
that is, do you think you're...
Are you doing any predictive
for like full game outcomes?
Do you see a future of that?
- All right, starting
with a tough two-parter.
Certainly, you know, as the
game evolves, the video game,
I don't wanna speak for the folks at 2K,
but we certainly are work with them
and provide data to them and
help them in any way they can.
But ultimately, like,
they're video game experts,
and I'm not that.
But it's a good question,
and I'm sure they're looking at all ways
to make the game more realistic.
On the predictive side, yes, we do.
We are the league office.
We don't always want to predict
who's winning or losing the game
because we are the neutral
third-party arbiters of the game.
But we do use things like
win probability models
under the hood to help
inform what content to serve
and things like that.
So, yeah, we absolutely do
predictive things like that.
- [Audience Member] and
that win probability model
is underlying the Leverage Score.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- So how do we find
those moments that have high swings,
potential swings in win probability
to be a leverage moment, so...
- Exactly.
So that Leverage Score that's coming,
although it's not directly,
but you can often think of it
as how did the players' contributions
move their teams win probability.
Right?
And obviously your contributions
in clutch close games
are gonna move the win probability
more than the beginning of the game,
but that's part of basketball.
And which players perform
in those situations
and a rebound and a steel moves
win probability a lot too.
So while we may not surface
exactly the win probability,
it's a very important factor
to that Leverage Score
that goes into it.
Over here.
- [Audience Member] Quick question.
Do you guys track foul calls?
- We track foul calls, certainly.
I mean, we need to know when
a player gets the six fouls,
so they can't play anymore.
- [Audience Member] No, I'm saying like,
every time a coach or a team
or owner sends that type of
information to the league
and say, "Hey, this is clear cut footage
that this is a foul call."
- So that's the basketball
operations department,
not our team in terms of,
that's internal process between
the teams and the league.
(indistinct)
- [Audience Member] So do you ever...
Do you think you'll ever track like...
'Cause if you have sensors on the players,
you could technically, if
there's like pressure points,
you could see when they got fouled,
if they got fouled, right?
- So we don't...
29 body points per player is a lot,
but not necessarily enough
to know things like that
in terms of content and, you know?
But you never know what
technology is around the corner.
And certainly we're looking at
ways to use the data to help,
you know, automate officiating things
and improve the flow of the game
and things along those lines.
- And just to be clear,
the skeletal pose data,
there's no sensors on the players.
In the NFL, they have
sensors in the shoulder pads
for Next Gen Stats.
In NBA, it's all optical tracking.
So it's all generated off of video
to build that full post data set.
So there's no like
actual sensors deployed.
- [Audience Member] Okay,
and then last question,
do you ever think we'll
have like a robot ref.
- Listen, that's your limit
on controversial questions.
(crowd laughing)
You've already...
- No, Adam Silverman said hi.
(Dash laughs)
- [Brian] Yeah.
Hi, Brian Jackson with
Info-Tech Research Group.
I know that NBA teams have
their own analytics departments
that might be trying to suss out
some of these more advanced metrics
even before the NBA would, right?
So do you feel that, like, by releasing
these advanced metrics,
that maybe you're sort of democratizing
that intelligence across the league?
- Certainly anything we
build, our team builds,
we are gonna share with all of our teams,
NBA, WNBA, et cetera.
We wanna make sure they have access
and that they can do what
they wanna do with it,
and then what teams do
and their competitive
advantage is up to them.
But we definitely talk to our teams
and what would be helpful to them
and what would be meaningful
and help their workflows
not just from a data science standpoint,
from a data delivery and
a logistics standpoint
and cloud infrastructure
and how do we get the data to them easier
with less state engineering
and less ETL process.
So, we're in touch with teams all the time
and absolutely wanna help
them run more efficiently
and get the insights they
need to run their business.
- [Sam] Hi, I'm Sam Meyer from BMS.
Thank you for this.
I have two questions.
The first one is,
how do you account for the
propensity of the defense
to help or not when it
comes to the gravity score?
I'm curious about that.
And then also, are you
thinking about anything
that's sort of the inverse of
the gravity score for defense
or like a wimpy factor, if you will?
- You can take that.
- That's a funny one.
Someone did bring that up to me.
It's a little bit more
difficult to tease out on...
I'm taking the second question first.
A little bit more difficult to tease out
because you'd have to figure out what,
you know, you have to give the information
about where the defense is, right?
And once you do that,
the game's kind of up.
You know where they are,
not where they would otherwise be, right?
It's a tricky question.
It's been brought up.
We're thinking about it, for sure.
Like, which players on defense
push the offensive way.
Like, they don't want to
come near Wembanyama, right?
It's definitely on our minds,
but how to solve that problem
is something we're still thinking
through and talking about.
And then your first question is,
by using a season's worth of data, right?
We downsample a little bit.
We're doing 10 frames a second here.
We account for, hopefully,
all of those different moments in time.
The model takes in two
seconds worth of input data
and we're deploying it
with at least, you know,
we can have 25% of that massed out.
So within half a second
of the players coming over half court,
we're calculating that gravity metric
or running that expected
defensive pressure score model,
you know, at 10 frames a second.
And so we hope by training the
model over a season of data,
we find those situations
where help versus no help.
All teams do it differently, right?
Where's the average defender
on this play, right?
And that's how we can tell
that over help situation
is when that player really steps over
and increases that defensive pressure
on that player above the expectation.
So it's really just a
volume question, I think,
to kind of tease out that help situation.
If that's a strategy to take it away,
we wanna understand that.
Because if you're deploying your help,
you're leaving someone else open, right?
And that's a high gravity
moment that we want to capture
and may hopefully leads
to a high expected field
goal percentage shot, right?
And we can tie all these things together
and tell really great stories
about how teams are creating
value on the offensive end.
- Yeah, if you look at the play we showed
when Clarkson comes over as
a third defender on Giannis,
you can see the gravity score
is going up significantly.
So we're using all of those
25 pair ways DPS scores
from all the defenders
to each of their offensive
players throughout,
and, yeah, the secondary defender,
the third defender comes over,
has a big impact on gravity.
- [Audience Member] Hi.
Not to turn this into an engineering talk,
but, like, can you give
us a quick overview
of not just the model
you're using, but also-
- That corner.
- [Audience Member] Also,
how are you guys serving
a model fast enough
for like a real-time
prediction during a game?
- Sorry, start again.
I was lost.
I couldn't find you.
- [Audience Member] Yeah, no worries.
Without going into much (indistinct),
can you give us kind of a quick overview
of how the machine learning
model actually works,
and then how are you
serving it fast enough
to give real-time
predictions during a game?
- Yep.
Take it again.
(Ian laughs)
- So like I said,
we are using an inference server
located in the same node pool, right,
that we're sending these crews to
or make sure we're scaled
and that those are equipped
with the right machine sizes
to handle the load
of the concurrent games that are going on.
So we're sending those queries.
We're also, you know,
using a dynamic batching
on those inference servers
to basically take any
queries that come in within,
let's say, a few
milliseconds of each other
to batch those together and run
inference on the same thing.
So when we have 10
concurrent games going on,
we can actually do
inference more efficiently
with those servers, right?
That's how we're doing it.
As far as the details of the model,
we've tried a couple of
different architectures,
and I'm going to have to
defer to the data scientists.
But based on, other than
what I talked about,
we did try some simple
CatBoost XGBoost out options,
but we found, over time, that
with factorized attention
at the transformer architecture
where we're able to,
the model is able to
learn the relationships
between players in space and time
over the course of that two-second
window that we're feeding
was the most accurate overall.
And so that's where we decided
to go with that architecture.
- Next year, Dash, 500 level.
- Absolutely.
- You gotta do it.
- How we're getting to
subsecond latency bit by bit.
- Yeah.
- Absolutely.
- And maybe they could move
the tire changing closer.
- Yes.
- Yeah, that'd be next year.
- Yeah, the only other
thing I'd highlight too
is we're really excited to see
what each of the broadcast partners do
with that live data, right?
So, Gravity will be
available in sub-second,
and you start to see some
of the stuff Ian showed
in the graphics,
but how do you overlay that
in real-time on the video
and see how does that
third defender come over
Spike Gianni's gravity, for example.
Do they show that as a number?
Do they show that as a size of a bar?
I think, you know, working
with their graphics teams,
we're really excited to see where they go
and how they start to show
that to fans in live games.
- Yeah, and that's an interesting
point on the, you know,
sub-second latency, looking
to achieve that through moving
that actual defensive pressure score
from a calculation of different
sub-scores to a model.
By including the defense
back into the model, right,
and including that additional data point,
we're actually able to
predict more accurately
the actual defensive
pressure score in the moment.
And then by using
inference on the raw data,
as opposed to calculating features,
we'll be able to serve up
gravity as subsecond latency.
So it's been a really interesting
to see how the model reacts differently
when you include the
defense versus you don't
in similar architectures in it,
how the different approaches are better
for the different models.
But that's what we're moving towards
for the subsecond latency gravity.
- [Audience Member] Hello.
Thank you, again, for having us.
Nice shoes.
I could listen to you talk
about NBA stats all day,
and you have a great broadcasting voice.
My question is, is this data
gonna be available for fans
in order, like, through
an API or something
in order to empower them
to maybe create their own advanced metrics
or develop stats later on?
- Thank you for the compliments.
Appreciate it.
Certainly, it'll be available
through our products, right?
And putting the leaderboards on.
But the raw data, we're
looking at potentially ways
of doing that through,
you know, hackathons
and things like that,
but nothing formal yet.
But appreciate that there's interest
- You can go today to nba.com
and see all of the shots taken
and get the expected field
goal shot for both teams.
You can see how they shot
overexpected, underexpected,
the actual field goal percentage
versus their expected
field goal percentage.
So all of that data is now available
on the NBA's digital sites
to be able to look at.
- [Audience Member] I was
really trying to find out
the 29 skeletal points 60 times a second.
That would be amazing
if we could get that.
- We appreciate the interest.
Again, back to the 500 talk.
Back for the (indistinct).
- And spinning up your own cluster
to manage all the storage and...
- [Audience Member] Going
back to the data points
that are in the model,
like the defensive data
points, are those the,
like depending on the actual player...
Like, the defensive...
Like, who the player is or
just that they're a defender?
- No, so the data points in the model,
like, if you're talking about calculating
actual defensive pressure scores, right,
all of that is player agnostic.
So it's more based on the
2D locations of the players.
We have goals and aspirations
to actually improve that
using player orientation
and where they're looking over time.
Right now that we have this
3D player tracking data,
you don't necessarily
need to use all 29 points,
but it's really cool to be able to see
the hip orientation of the players,
which way they're facing.
So what's going into that actual
defensive pressure is all,
this is all player agnostic
on the model front,
and that's what allows us to calculate
that actual over expected
'cause we just basically
assume every player is the same
with the model, right,
and the calculation,
and then we see specifically which players
are drawing that attention.
- [Audience Member] Did
you also make that decision
because you didn't want to have
to, like, retrain the model
each year as, like, new players came in?
Or I guess, also, are you expecting
to have to, like, retrain the model
based on any changes to rules
or anything, like, year over year?
- Yeah.
Something that we're discussing
is how to best service year over year
because there's changes in strategy.
One thing we've noticed with
the defensive pressure score,
or, sorry, with the expected
defensive pressure score models
is that gravity is higher this
year compared to last year.
And that's, if you've heard the discourse
that teams are pressuring up more, right?
So directionally, gravity is
still a very powerful metric.
But compared to last year,
you're gonna see different
magnitudes of gravity
because defensive are
taking a different strategy.
And funny enough, two years ago, you know,
we saw higher gravity's there as well.
So for whatever reason last year,
and, you know, this is the discourse
we love to have and love to
understand the game better.
This year, that strategy pushed
everyone's pressuring more
leads to higher gravities.
Now, like I said.
Ordinarily, the
leaderboards and everything
still makes sense,
but we have had conversations
about when do we retrain,
when has strategy trained
enough that we need to retrain
to better serve, you know, or
to understand the game, right?
- Cool, thank you.
- Yeah.
- [Ben] Hello.
Hi, Ben Shalel.
Thank you.
This is fantastic.
I love this.
I was wondering if you
do any audio tracking
and if maybe there was an opportunity
to do like a smack talk leaderboard.
I know that's big on the court.
I think people would love that.
So I was wondering if you
thought about that at all.
- It would be interesting.
I'll say, yes, we've thought about it,
but I don't think that
would be forthcoming.
But-
- Not the first person
suggests tracking what is said
and trying to translate
it to data in some way.
But, you know, a lot of
hurdles there and, you know?
- [Audience Member] From
a technical perspective,
there's an ability to do it
and to be able to separate
out different sounds.
Do you want background noise?
Do you want background noise
using some of the speech to speech models
and those sorts of things.
The ability to actually
hear what the players say,
I think the players' association
would have a lot to say about that
before it ever comes
out publicly, for sure.
- And they might change
what they're saying
if they knew they were all being mic'd up.
So then you're, you know?
- [Audience Member] As I
work in high school sports,
I'm curious how important
the video equipment itself is
in kind of grabbing some of these 29 poses
and everything like that of like,
could I do this with a
single camera in a gym?
How close could I get?
Or is the video equipment
really helping out?
- Really, it's a question for Hawkeye,
our vendor who builds the
player tracking system.
Our team takes that raw
29 points per player
and works with that data,
but we don't necessarily
do the computer vision.
That's our vendor.
However, you know, from a
computer vision background,
again, back when I used
to operate at 500 level,
like, it would,
the technology's improved a lot
and there's a lot you
can do with one camera.
But whether you would
get 50% or 70% or 80%
of what we have with 20
cameras and 60 frames a second,
I'm not sure.
But, you know, it is impressive
what some companies are
doing with one camera
in a more amateur high school setting.
Yeah, it's definitely coming.
- And I think the problem
you run into with one camera
is just occlusion, right?
It's one thing that we
deal with on the NBA side,
is that where, you know...
Before this season, we were looking at,
you know, fixed length
joints for joint positions
that were high occlusion zones, right?
The hip joints and the finger joints,
it's hard to determine where
they are in space sometimes.
But our vendor was able to
improve that with the upgrades
and the number of cameras they have
to be able to go to variable lengths.
But that's really the problem
you're probably gonna run into
with a single camera, is
once that player runs...
Once I stand behind Charlie,
you can't get any of mine.
You're just guessing, right?
So...
- In a former life, I
did a master's thesis
on tracking the basketball
in the high school team I was coaching,
and then I quickly realized
there was a vendor doing it
way better than I would
ever do it by myself.
So while it got me the master's,
that was the end of that project.
- I would, I would say
that is the goal, though,
over time, right?
As you see this technology...
You know, years ago, you'd
have to have 100 cameras
around a football field
to start to get some of this data,
then it goes down to 40, now in the teens.
So I think there's certainly, you know,
the pace of innovation is
such that getting to a point
where you can do it with
three cameras, then two,
and then hopefully ultimately
with one is certainly,
you know, I think a industry goal.
Whether, you know, who gets
there, how quickly that happens,
we'll be watching and seeing,
but it's certainly where
that evolution is happening.
- [Chandra] Hi, Chandra
from Nielsen Sports,
partner with NBA.
So the audio tracking, we
do track brands on audio.
So probably you can partner
with us to catch that.
I had a question on the APIs.
We are partners, so do partners get access
to the data through APIs?
Would you know?
- Did you say NESN, the broadcast?
- Nielsen, Nielsen.
- Oh, Nielsen.
I'm sorry, Nielsen.
- Yeah.
- Happy to meet you after.
We can talk about it, sure.
I'm not the partnership person
to all the ins and outs,
but happy to talk with you about it.
- [Chandra] Perfect, thank you.
- [Audience Member] So
we've been hearing a lot
about agentic.
I love my NBA podcasts,
but sometimes, you know,
you don't know who's doing their research.
And when I go to nbastats.com,
it can be kind of overwhelming
to, like, see all the stats.
So have you thought about,
like, a chatbot agent
who really understands the stats,
so I can ask it detailed questions like,
why do the Clippers stink this year
or why are the Celtics
turning around lately,
those sort of things.
- Gonna pass the mic to the
people in the back corner.
Stay tuned.
Good question.
I'm not allowed to tip
anything, but good question.
You're onto something.
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
Can you apply this data
to historical footage?
Kind of going back to
the question from before,
you know, who has a better
gravity score, Michael or LeBron?
Like, you know, those sorts of comparisons
would be interesting to see.
- It's something we'd love to do,
and certainly something we looked at.
It's not quite there yet
from a technology standpoint,
but, you know, that'd be a
incredible world to live in.
- Well, not that far historically, right?
But one of the things is,
and the reason we've decided to build
these metrics the way that we have
and focusing on some of
these metrics on the 2D,
like Gravity is built
using the 2D tracking data mostly, right?
Or completely.
And that is to be able to
backfill it to the seasons,
all of the seasons for
which we have tracking.
But we do not have the
broadcast tracking back
to the Jordan era, unfortunately.
That's, you know...
- Yeah.
That grainy footage.
- Yeah, exactly.
- That be tough.
Thank you.
- Yeah, no problem.
- It'd be great to see what Gravity was
in the hand checking era
and not need to send a double because-
- Going back to how many models
(indistinct) for each era.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
No three point lines are incredible.
- [Audience Member] Hey,
guys, I was just wondering,
do you guys track any, like,
clutch metrics or like-
- Sorry, can you put the
mic up a little higher?
- Oh, sorry about that.
- There you go.
- [Audience Member] I was
wondering, do you guys track
any, like, clutch metrics,
you know, things that really
turn the tide of a game?
For example, like, Ray Allen's
three or "blocked by James."
Do you guys have any of those scores
assigned to each player?
- So, we will with the Leverage Score.
I think you're going to enjoy
what comes out here soon
with the Leverage Score.
But you can go on nba.com right now
and add our clutch filter,
which looks at the last
five minutes of games
when there's a five-point or
less deficit between teams.
And we've had that
standard for a long time
and look at how players have performed
when those clutch
situations are happening.
That's available right now,
but the Leverage Score will
enhance that in an exciting way
that I think will be right
in line with your question.
- Awesome, thank you.
- Okay.
- Good?
- Going once, going twice?
- Oh, wait.
One more.
- [Audience Member] Sorry.
Just one more question
since nobody else had one.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] I
didn't see on your roadmap
anything about the GOAT score.
When is that coming out?
(group laughing)
- We need the tracking
data back further, right?
- Yeah.
- Perfect.
- Oh.
Is there one right there?
- [Speaker] One more.
One more.
- [Audience Member] Hi.
I was wondering for,
when you release a new stat like gravity,
how do you measure like
the success of a stat?
Like, how much people
are engaging with it?
Yeah.
- It's a great question
that we struggle with
as the product management hat
of our team in a lot of ways.
The...
We talked about the North Star, which is,
How do we educate and engage fans.
But if you actually go
kind of page by page
to the app or the site,
stats are everywhere.
Our team does the scores,
the standings, the schedule,
and their components of lots
of different parts of the page.
And it's hard to assign an ROI
to any specific change we
make to the presentation
or one new stat in a box score.
It's hard to say how that stat impacted
the overall experience
and drew a page views
or any of the classic sort of
product management benchmarks
that you might look at.
And that's why we've adopted this idea of,
"All right, well, if we're
helping the discourse
and moving the basketball
analytics industry forward,
and ultimately that phrase
that we keep saying,
educating and engaging fans,
that's leading to good ROI
and good business outcomes.
And if broadcasters are wanting
it and teams are using it
and, you know, it becomes
part of basketball,
and that's a home run success for us.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- To plug our friends at Prime Video,
you can go across the
way to One Amazon Lane
where Prime Video was...
Right now they've got
NASCAR from this summer
and Thursday Night Football,
but they'll go very much into it with you
about how they see these
new advanced stats programs
driving viewership, engagement,
how much the producing teams
are putting them on screen.
So we're really excited to drive that
with each of these partners here
around how much these advance stats
are actually going on screen being used
or becoming a part of the dialogue.
I think all of those metrics are things
we'll start to look to
track both internally,
and then with the broadcast partners.
- All right.
- Thank you.
- Thanks, everyone.
- Thank you, this was great.
(crowd applauding)
Good work.
(Dash faintly speaking)